so with two years on from the referendum
a week of edging towards the brexit that
you always dreamed of it's a curious
process the negotiations with the
European Union and I mean I negotiated
with them in the early 2000s and one of
the key people I worked with or someone
called Michel Barnier and what I learned
there is that the negotiations will
always go up to the wire it's the
deadline so unless you have a deadline
nothing gets agreed but the the two
things which I think we much must not
lose sight of is on the one hand so far
the EU has achieved its strategic goals
and that was to make the process of
leaving as long-winded as complicated
and as painful as possible we on the
other hand our strategic goals seemed to
be to keep the Tory party together and
this is about more than that this is
about the national interest and if what
some people are concerned about is
uncertainty then surely getting to a
point where we end the uncertainty and
are clear about leaving the better for
all whether you were remainer or
reliever so do you miss résumés more
worried about her in party discipline
then than the breaks that do well she
needs to be worried about the party
discipline because that's what she
requires to implement the government
policy but now that we have the
withdrawal bill it's gone through
Parliament and we know we negotiating
heads of agreement we must have a
withdrawal treaty which is clear about
the broad principles and I could have to
pick up on your point that you met the
you negotiated alongside Michelle Barnea
how was he because he seems like an
extraordinary tough negotiator from an
outsider's point of view well he's a
he's a good man he's a decent man but at
heart he is a go list so I think in
private he probably sheds few tears
about the United Kingdom leaving then
you might think other than and this is
important the Union European Union is
losing its second largest net
contributor so the automatic payments
are one of our greatest bargaining tools
and therefore Theresa May must not agree
on anything that doesn't bring together
our payment and broad agreements well
it's already been given away
no no she hasn't because at the moment
we talked about we said we make
contributions but the restore treaty
will be more precise and wise people
talk about in a transition period I
think there must be implementation
period let's talk about the transition
period because it feels to me all the
interviews I've done recently
politicians seem to be lay in the ground
for a longer transition aspect ilium Fox
last weekend he said that he'd be happy
for the transition to be extended in
certain circumstances great Clark who
we'll hear from shortly effectively says
the same thing Jeremy Corbyn in the
interview that we've just heard he says
that he would also accept a longer
transition payors I mean for some people
who voted leave the bleakness thinking
are we ever going to leave the EU and
this is where you have to inquire into
people's motives as far as I'm concerned
and I think probably most people who
voted leave and some who voted remain
they say if we leave and we know how
we're going to leave then if that takes
a bit of time that's fine but we must be
clear on the terms on which we are
leaving so if you spell out precisely
what the agreement is and then someone
comes back and says you know in order to
make this happen it'll take us a little
bit longer then people will say that's
fine but a lot of people who talk about
extending negotiations extending those
periods they just don't want us to leave
at all and they hope that what you can
make temporary will become permanent so
the transition period is neither here
nor there
in one sense provided you start with
clear heads which you have the great
talking about people who don't like
there was some of the referendum maybe
them in your own party it feels as if
there is a growing momentum to corner
corner word to get a second referendum
on the final deal momentum members
voting to back this many of them unite
members accordingly apparently doing the
same are you worried that actually the
Labour Party position seems may shift
what I would say to both sides is that
uncertainty is
one thing which concerns business in
terms of investment it's the one thing
which many of the remains have
criticized about the process so far and
I think that if you if you motive for
calling for a second referendum is to
delay and overturn the decision then you
do two things you undermine democratic
institutions because we promised the
referendum and a prime minister said
whatever you decide I will implement it
and also you increased delay and
uncertainty and I can't see how that
could be good for anyone I'm talking
about the Jeremy Corbyn interview as
well that we just and listened to one
question that I asked him was whether
brexit was the problem or if it was the
government's handling of brexit and he
said it was a government handling so
there's been suspicions about Jeremy
Corbyn he of course denies it but do you
think that he has a certain sympathy
towards you know the brexit air cause
well I can observe is that why is spying
light in the 20 years I always was a
very loyal Labour Party backbencher
however I tended to break ground when
the word Europe was in legislation and
on those occasions Jeremy called we
tended to be in the same division Lobby
as me that is their own apart I think
there comes a moment were irrespective
of what you thought in the past and what
you think of the government's handling
what struck me over the last years we
seem to stop talking about the future we
kept talking about all kinds of past
years and my challenge to both the
cabinet but also to her front bench is
let's look ahead the world around us is
changing technology trade deals
international conditions let's make the
UK fit for the future and that requires
a little bit more confidence and let's
show it and now you of course with a
chair about leave lots of people have
really criticised the campaign though
don't leave ran and you know from you
know the 350 million pounds to the NHS
on the side of the bus that some people
say is just simply not a correct figure
also if you look back at some of the
vote leave press releases they do seem
slightly naive in tone some of them I
mean after we vote leave we would
immediately be able to start negotiating
new trade deals with the world's biggest
economies means you ever look back
pain and feel a bit uncomfortable and
think actually you know what we did
oversimplify some things there but when
you ask a question which are kind of
constitutional questions it wasn't if
you'd had a referendum on say the Lisbon
Treaty where you could say this is a
treaty and this is what we have now when
you do than those broad principles I
think the thing which we kept coming
back to and which is the real difference
is who do you think should make you laws
who do you think should do your trade
deals I understand that those were the
arguments that you made during that
campaign you know very eloquently but
did you not feel a bit uncomfortable at
some of the other people around you in
the campaign and the way that they did
seem to be simplifying some of those
arguments I think when you run a
campaign all you can ever do is focus on
what you say and vote leaf we were very
careful with for example language and
immigration we never talked about
numbers we actually always said the
system should be the same whether you're
citizens or non EU citizen we actually
talked closer towards the end of the
campaign about an Australian style point
system which is actually one thing
remain as an lever seem to agree on and
we had to take people to talking about
things we haven't talked about for 40
years
and remember members of parliament
haven't talked about trade deals and
trade negotiations for 40 years oh well
they're making up right now certainly
and there's lots of things in the papers
today as well about conservative
leadership at all so just before you go
I'm keen to get your thoughts on two
people whose names often mentioned to
people you worked very closely with in
vote leave Boris Johnson and Michael
Gove I think I owe them a prime minister
material well what I answer come on it's
the process of the campaign's which will
metal whoever it is but I have to say
that I've I've enjoyed working with both
of them and I don't think their public
image does some justice okay thank you
very much